[Music]  this year marks the 25th anniversary of  the establishment of the hong kong sar  we must continue  to ensure the comprehensive  accurate  and firm implementation  of the principles of one country two  systems  hong kong people  administering hong kong and the high  degree of autonomy  to maintain our long-term  prosperity and stability  [Music]  [Music]  this result was never in doubt john lee  was a sole candidate in this election he  secured  1416 votes 98 turnout as to what sort of  chief executive he'll make well the  coming weeks and months will tell but  john lee is certainly a man who has the  backing the support of beijing otherwise  he wouldn't be in that position he was  also a career policeman he was in the  force for more than 40 years so he is a  man that knows a security situation here  in hong kong inside out he played a very  decisive role in suppressing the  pro-democracy protest in 2019  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  you